I think a lot of people just assume that
the way to make more intelligent just to
make them more human,
but
I think that's a very dubious
assumption.
I think we're much better off with tools
with colleagues.
We can make tools that are smart as the
Dickens and use them and understand what
their limitations are without giving
them ulterior motives,
purposes,
a drive to exist and to compete and to
beat the others.
Those are features that don't play any
crucial role in the competences of
artificial intelligence,
so for Heaven Sakes,
don't bother putting them in.
Leave all that out and what we have is
very smart things that we can treat like
slaves and it's quite all right to treat
them as less because they.
They don't have feelings.
They're not conscious.
You can turn them off.
You can tear them apart the same way you
can with an automobile and that's the
way we should keep it.
Now that we're in the age of intelligent
design,
lots of intelligent designers around.
A lot of them are intelligent enough to
realize that Oracle's second rule is
true.
Evolution is cleverer than you are.
That's Francis Crick's,
famous quip,
and so what they're doing is harnessing
evolutionary processes to do the heavy
lifting without human help,
so we have all these deep learning
systems and they kind of in the
varieties,
there's basie and networks and and a
reinforcement learning of various sorts
of deep,
deep learning neural networks and what
these computer systems have in common is
that they are competent without
comprehension.
Google translate doesn't know what he's
talking about when it translates a bit
of Turkish into a bit of English,
doesn't have to.
It's not as good as the translation that
a bilingual can do,
but it's good enough for most purposes.
And what's happening in many fields in
this new wave of ai is the creation of
systems.
Black boxes where you know that the
probability of getting the right answer
is very high.
They are extremely good.
They're better than human beings at
churning through the data and coming up
with the right answer,
but they don't understand how they do
it.
Nobody understands in detail how they do
I know,
but he has to.
So we've created entities which are his
inscrutable to us as a bird or a mammal
considered as a collection of cells.
This inscrutable is still a lot we don't
understand about what makes them tick
and we can use these products,
these intellectual products without
knowing quite how they're generated,
but knowing having a good responsible
reasons for believing that they will
generate the truth.
Most of the time,
no existing computer system,
no matter how good it is,
that answering questions like Watson on
jeopardy knows how the system is
conscious today,
not close.
And although I think it's possible in
principle to make a conscious android,
the conscious robot,
I don't think it's desirable.
I don't think there would be great
benefits to doing this and there'll be
some significant harms and dangerous to
you could at tremendous expense,
but you'd have to have in fact that
quite a quite a revolution in in
computer design,
which would take you right down,
right down to the very base of the
hardware.